alors la première que pensez-vous du
conflit entre la russie et l'ukraine la
france devrait elle intervenir je
réponds tôt suite à la seconde question
non la france n'est ni alliés de la
russie ni alliés d'ukraine elle n'est
pas partie intégrante de cette guerre la
russie n'a pas déclaré la guerre à la
france d'ailleurs les manuels mâcon le
dit
donc nous devons au contraire tout faire
pour trouver une solution pacifique
nous étions déjà avant d'ailleurs
responsable des fameux accords de minsk
entre la russie et l'ukraine qui
définissait un certain nombre de
critères et nous n'avons c'est le
reproche que je fais d'ailleurs à
maquereau et même un hollande avant et à
madame merkel qui était nous étions
coresponsable
de ne pas avoir fait appliquer ces
accords de minsk je pense qu'il n'y
aurait pas eu de guerre aujourd'hui
c'est l'accord de minsk qui prévoyait
l'autonomie du dombass qui prévoyait le
principe de que l'ukraine ne rentrerai
pas dans l'otan les américains ont
préféré
conserver la possibilité de ce qu'on
appelle la porte ouverte c'est à dire la
porte ouverte à l'ukraine et d'ailleurs
j'ai vu il ya quelques jours
monsieur gourdault montagne qui était le
conseiller diplomatique de jacques
chirac racontait qu'en 2006 jacques
chirac avait proposé une garantie
croisée de l'ukraine par l'otan et par
la russie avec comme principe le fait
que l'ukraine ne rentrerai pas dans
l'auto et les américains ont refusé et
ont très mal reçu d'ailleurs l'envoyé de
jacques chirac alors zielinski n'était
le président ukrainien devant les
députés français ce mercredi la demande
et que renault au chant et leroy merlin
a quitté la russie et cesser d'être les
sponsors de la guerre est ce que pour
vous toutes les entreprises françaises
doivent cesser d'entretenir des liens
avec la russie
vous savez je veux bien qu'on prenne des
sanctions contre poutine parce que il a
effectivement agressé le cren il a
effectivement de façon scandaleuse pas
respecter sa souveraineté ses frontières
etc oui il est l'agresseur mais n'avons
pas à nous tirer des balles dans le pied
voire dans la tête vous savez ceux qui
financent vous savez ceux qui financent
la guerre aujourd'hui de poutine c'est
nos achats de gaz et vous savez qui
achète le gaz ce sont les allemands
alors quand les allemands cesseront
d'acheter leur gaz qui leur permet de se
chauffer qui leur permet de faire
tourner leurs usines parce qu'ils sont
dépendants à 60% du gaz russe eh bien
les français pourront commencer à
prendre des mesures moi je ne veux pas
que cette guerre
se fasse au détriment de l'économie
française et des entreprises françaises
il faut raison garder il faut défendre
nos intérêts alors qu'eric zemmour
en descendent septembre 2018 vous étiez
interviewé par nicolas beytout à
l'opinion et vous dites dans une réponse
à une de ces questions est ce que vous
rêvez d'un poutine français vous dire
oui je rêve d'un poutine français c'est
une phrase qu'on ressort aujourd'hui
cela ressort est-ce que vous rêvez
toujours d'un poutine français mais
qu'est ce que j'ai voulu dire il ya
maintenant presque quatre ans j'ai voulu
dire que vladimir poutine avait pris un
pays qui était ruiné qui était sorti de
là la fin de l'urss
absolument en ruine et avec des
dirigeants pitoyable comme seuil alstyne
qui était un alcoolique notoire et qui
avait vendu ce pays aux à la fois aux
oligarques et aux américains donc il a
simplement
redresser son pays à l'époque vous savez
jacques chirac ne disait pas autre chose
nicolas sarkozy ne disait pas autre
chose donc quand je disais un putin
français je voulais dire un patriote
français français parution qui redresse
ce pays et qui aime son pays qui défend
farouchement les intérêts de son pays ni
plus ni moins je ne comptais pas ni
attaqué l'italie ni attaquer l'allemagne
y avait quand même une dimension je
prends un peu civilisationnel dans notre
admiration pour vladimir poutine vous y
voyez et vous l'avez souvent écrit un
rempart chrétiens contre l'immigration
ou l'invasion pour reprendre le terme
venant du sud défenseurs des valeurs des
valeurs que vous considérez comme forte
notamment de la famille ou déjà l'heure
où des valeurs ou des valeurs
culturelles qu'il pouvait incarner
comment est ce que vous voyez
aujourd'hui la dîmière poutine agressant
l'ukraine avec des tchétchènes qui
crient allah ouakbar avant d'intervenir
dans les
je vous avoue que c'est troublant ce qui
prouve d'ailleurs que dans la guerre
tout est possible et qu'on monte assez
vite aux extrêmes je vois d'ailleurs
qu'il y a aussi des islamistes
tchétchènes du côté des ukrainiens j'ai
lu ça dans le figaro voyez comme quoi
dans la guerre tout est possible on est
prêt à tout pour gagner on le sait
d'ailleurs nous mêmes nous n'avons
jamais lésiné se prendre des troupes
mesures diverses lomé c'est pour vous
dire que dans la guerre après il n'y a
plus de principe c'est ça que je veux
dire poutine le démontre vous avez
raison ça me fend le coeur de voir des
islamistes tchétchènes massacrer des
ukrainiens chrétien mais de l'autre côté
il y a des tchétchènes qui sont avec les
ukrainiens et par ailleurs je vous dis
dans les troupes vous savez dans les
armées françaises dans l'histoire de
france on appris de tout ça soit dans la
grande armée de napoléon que ce soit
dans les grandes armées de louis xiv que
ce soit dans la guerre de
14 dernière chose ça aux facteurs mais
ce que vous dites aussi je me suis
complètement planté et admire plein non
je me si vous voulez ce qu'est ce que je
dis je jo croit vous savez il faudrait
reprendre ça dans son contexte mais on
n'a pas énormément de temps mais très
vite quand le lempire soviétique meurt
quand le communisme c'est flou il y a
deux thèses qui s'affrontent de thèse
philosophique intellectuelle sur
l'avenir la thèse de fukuyama qui est
tout va aller bien tout la démocratie
libérale deviendra le paradigme absolue
et puis la thèse de huntington qui est
pas du tout nous allons vers un conflit
de civilisations entre l'orient et
l'occident entre l'islam et la
chrétienté je crois depuis le début à
cette test donc jeudi il y à un conflit
de civilisations et dans ce conflit de
civilisation je préfère que un chrétien
orthodoxe comme poutine comme la russie
soit avec nous avec l'europe plutôt que
avec la chine moi président je ferai
tout pour cela pour qu'il y ait un
ensemble européen et que la russie ne se
jette pas dans les bras de la chine
comme on le fait aujourd'hui voilà c'est
tout ok j'essaie d'être cohérent de
façon géostratégique vous pouvez avancer
cependant la question suivante voilà sur
la table sur la tablette que pensez-vous
de l'union rappelle aujourd'hui faute il
l'a quittée par rejoindre d'autres pays
moment
gehin je ne veux pas quitter l'union
européenne 2 je pense que la france ne
défend pas assez ses intérêts qu avec
emmanuel macron elle sacrifie tout à une
chimère de fédéralisme européen des
états unis d'europe de défense
européenne tout ça n'existe pas et
n'existera pas
3 je pense qu'il faut défendre avant
tout les intérêts de la france dans
l'union européenne sans la quitter et je
note d'ailleurs que je le ferai pour le
sujet majeur de l'immigration c'est à
dire que je ne je préviens d'avancé que
je ne respecterait pas les traités et
les jurisprudences européennes pour
sauver mon peuple du grand remplacement
mais que je ne suis pas le seul vous
savez à ne pas respecter les traités la
commission européenne passe son temps à
ne pas respecter les traités que ce soit
pour les aides d'état dustrit yale pour
ça soit la santé où elle est intervenue
alors qu'elle n'aurait pas dû intervenir
la banque centrale européenne non plus
n'a pas respecté les traiter voilà donc
il faut défendre les intérêts de la
france dans une union européenne
dont il faut arrêter les développements
fédéraux et l'extension des compétences
de la commission merci alors la notion
de grands emplacements les gens qui nous
écoutent et émoussé sur brut ont vu
d'ailleurs des éléments sur sur ce
concept
ils ont vu sans doute des éléments
effectivement mais qui ne sont pas les
miens je pense que le grand emplacement
c'est vous savez vous sortez dans la rue
vous aller n'importe où vous allez en
banlieue parisienne et vous voyez des
villes où on n'est plus en france c'est
à dire où les burqas et les voiles ont
remplacé les robes et les jupes ou les
kebabs l'ont replacé les bistrots où les
boucheries halal on remplaçait les
boucheries française où le ou la
librairie halal a remplacé la librairie
est celle où les femmes ne veulent plus
dans les cafés c'est ça le grand
remplacement c'est que à partir d'un
certain nombre de
populations
immensément musulmane impose
son mode de vie et ses moeurs et sa
civilisation et disparaît encore et
disparaît la cible et son concept gt à
aulnay il ya quelques jours est un jeune
homme qui habite à aubervilliers me
disais que à aubervilliers dans les
boutiques on ne parle plus français et
que et dans la rue il n'ya que des
djellabas et que des
des voiles et des burqas voilà voilà
aujourd'hui une ville prétendument
française qui n'est plus français c'est
ça le grand place assez bonne vision
parfois un peu caricatural
aulnay-sous-bois lucie pas mal de fois
et c'est parce que je vous parle
d'aubervilliers aubervilliers dans les
sous-bois ya des enclaves mais dans
toute la wilaya leur assise à tous à
verviers a parlé à ce jeune homme vous
verrez mais on n'y a là aussi on va
aussi sur place que des gens bas par
français qui est plein de commerces fin
que la vie se passe aussi trahi copé
sait pas ce qu'il me dit il puis dans le
grand emplacement et on klaus a quand
même bien aussi c'est aussi l'idée d'une
organisation de ce grand emplacement par
des élites pas du tout qui concerne
ainsi quand on lit renaud camus c'est ce
qui était c'est pas du tout ce qu'écrit
renaud camus renaud camus dit que c'est
un processus historiques démographiques
j'ai lu renaud camus et je le connais
bien donc voilà ce qu'il écrit
maintenant qu'il y ait des organismes je
vais répondre à votre question
honnêtement l'onu a parlé de grands
emplacements pour cent pour cent pour
cent pour le favoriser l'onu il y à des
conférences de l'onu en faveur du
remplacement de population c'est entre
guillemets de populations africaines et
européennes par les populations
africaines c'est écrit noir sur blanc
dans les résolutions de l'onu mais ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il ya un grand complot
pour remplacer les populations par une
autre il y à un phénomène démographique
est aujourd'hui les français ont le
choix entre
la démographie et la politique là si la
démographie continue en 2050 2060 il y a
une majorité
musulmane en france et la france les
pulls abondera total hors de question
d'acheter son intégration qu'est ce que
ça peut être une résolution à cette
question que vous évoquez ici la
suivante session suivante
si vous êtes élu président quelle sera
votre première destination à l'étranger
que sont courtes réponses courtes
réponses courtes il ya deux possibilités
soit je vais je pourrais parler de deuil
en soit je vais dans les capitales des
grands pays du conseil de sécurité comme
la france etats unis russie chine
angleterre
pour aider au règlement de cette
question ukrainienne soit je vais dans
les pays du maghreb algérie tunisie
maroc et d'autres pays africains pour
évaluer
effectivement le ce que ce que j'ai
appelé la remise gracieuse c'est-à-dire
leur voix des
étrangers clandestins des étrangers
comment dire délinquants des étrangers
criminels dans leurs pays respectifs des
mineurs isolés et c'est que je revois
alors par tous ceux il faut absolument
qu'on organise avec ces pays là le
retour de ces étrangers qui sont chez
nous indésirable vous avez premier
minister absolue à cette question là on
y reviendra tout à l'heure d'accord on
va voir une nouvelle partie des
séquences sur la question suivante
monsieur eric zemmour est ce que vous
allez établir une égalité salariale
entre les hommes et les femmes pour le
même boulot mais d'abord ce n'est pas
moi qui décide comme ça en claquant des
doigts qui lie à une égalité salariale
entre les uns et les autres mais à
travail égal salaire égal à travail égal
compétences égales
j'allais dire durée de travail égal
évidemment que le principe et l'égalité
salariale et qu'il faut le faire
respecter maintenant simplement ce que
je dis c'est que les chiffres avancés de
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes sont la plupart du temps
fantaisiste car ils ne tiennent pas
compte de ce que j'ai dit c'est à dire
les différences de métier choisi les
différences de durée de travail est
comparable comparables
trois passants c'est quand même c'est
déjà trop c'est déjà trop comme déjà
trop mais c'est pas les les 25% qu'on
affiche régulièrement c'est ça que je
devrais 2-0 comment une filiation vous
avez raison ça devrait être zéro mais
après il y à vous savez il faut
évidemment continuer à sanctionner les
entreprises qui ne respectent pas cette
stricte égalité 2 mais après on est dans
l'humain c'est à dire qu'on est dans le
l'évaluation des talents personnels
voyez après on additionne et on dit ah
les femmes sont moins payées mais après
c'est chaque cas individuel il faut
comprendre ça 5% c'est pas énorme mais
c'est en ces normes ce et aux roses est
encore trop tôt encore trop oui mais ça
va se réduire savard d'inéluctable le
mans se réduire et de toute façon il y a
déjà des mesures de prise il ya déjà des
mesures de prise donc ça va se régler ne
sont fut le sujet c'est le choix des
métiers en fait on a le choix entre la
liberté et l'égalité on voit que dans
les pays scandinaves les pays qui ont le
plus fait pour l'égalité
les femmes choisissent le plus souvent
est massivement des métiers entre
guillemets féminin et donc qui sont le
plus souvent moins bien payé dans la
sonde social dans la santé etc dans
l'éducation etc c'est leur choix elles
ont le droit elles ont le droit de faire
le métier qui leur plaisent vous pensez
que c'est un choix et qu'il n'y a pas
une société qui pousse les femmes à
choisir plutôt ce genre d'examen de
l'auto que des métiers de de
commandement par exemple absolument je
pense j'ai inscrit dans les gènes non
les métiers de commandement tout le
monde commente dans son secteur c'est
pas ça c'est pas la différence de
différence s'ils choisissent pas diabaye
choisirait ont choisi pas des métiers de
commandes normalement dans choisi des
métiers dans les secteurs santé et
éducation
ou alors ingénieur dans la finance et
ses rangs que ce sera moi je n'y renonce
et c'est le retrouve moi vous savez par
contre je vous donne un exemple j'ai une
amie qui a maintenant une quarantaine
d'années qui a été une élève très
brillante qui a fait les mines voyez
supérieur très en mathématiques et
matières scientifiques elle a commencé
dans la finance etc ça ne lui plaisait
pas voyez elle gagné beaucoup d'argent
mais ça ne lui plaisait pas ni
l'ambiance ni le métier aujourd'hui elle
s'occupe d'art elles gagnent beaucoup
moins sa vie vous allez dire elle est
allée discriminer non c'est son choix
vous nous donner un exemple une histoire
et vous en faites une généralisant c'est
vous qui faites jared spool moi je dis
il faut que les gens aient le choix
et pourquoi alors dans ce cas là ne pas
augmenter le salaire des formations des
fonctions dites féminines et alors là
vous savez là vous êtes dans une
critique globale du capitalisme vous
avez le droit vous avez le droit vous
savez on a vu comment ça se poser quand
on veut imposer à l'économie des règles
aussi impérieuse ça finit dans le
communisme est dans la misère ou choisir
moi je suis pour la liberté je suis pour
l'économie de marché je suis pour le
mérite quel que soit le sexe le mérite
l'effort le mérite je ne connais que ça
et je ne crois pas à vos thèses
sociologique qui détermine les têtes je
n'y crois pas je pense précède
déterminisme je pense que ces idéologies
il n'y a pas de déterminer c'est faux
d'accord au sujet des familles et des
propos de votre part qui ont choqué vous
avez dit en 2013 qu elle n'incarne pas
le pouvoir que le pouvoir s'évapore dès
qu'elle arrive est ce que pour vous ça
veut dire une femme ne peut pas diriger
l'entreprise qu'elle ne peut pas diriger
le pays j'ai parlé depuis le début
d'ailleurs j'ai revu avant de venir vous
voir
cesser ces citations et jeudi déjà à
l'époque le féminin et le masculin et je
dis à chaque fois il y à des exceptions
évidemment je me saoule je sais je parle
de catherine ii de russie par exemple
dans notre exemple dans le tas de chair
plus récents je parlais de type 2
féminin et deux masculins
évidemment dans l'histoire de l'humanité
dans l'histoire de l'humanité vous voyez
le grand universitaire emmanuel todd a
fait un livre récemment sur les hommes
et les femmes aiment universitaire de
gauche je précise qu'ils ne pas léser
les du sujet mais c'est pas rien
maintenant il a travaillé dessus c'est
tout vous savez les spécialistes peuvent
se tromper et des généralistes moi j'ai
lu l'histoire des mentalités a été
inventé par des gens qui laisse à
l'historien vous savez comme philippe
ariès qui se qualifie lui-même de films
de l'historienne dimanche une grande
histoire vous voyez on est d'accord là
dessus
et il était spécialiste de rien
donc il a bien expliqué par exemple la
différenciation entre les chasseurs
cueilleurs vous savez alors à l'aube de
l'humanité mais de dire que si le
pouvoir est aux mains des formes il se
dilapide je dis ça je dis je parlais de
masculins et deux féminins deux grands
types et j'expliquais simplement des
sociologies et des imaginaires mais je
vais pas placer la campagne a parlé de
ça oui ce sont des propos vous avez tenu
à mais c'est les propos que j'ai tenus
avec j'assume je vous dis que vous en je
parle du féminin et du masculin
saison suivante et la question suivante
aussi justement quand on parle au sujet
des femmes sur mediapart six à huit
femmes justement qui vous accusent de
comportement inapproprié d'agression
sexuelle pour des faits présumés allant
de 1989 à 2019 qu'est ce que vous
répondez vous à ces accusations très
simple je n'ai jamais agressé aucune
femme
voilà comme par hasard ça sort trois
semaines avant le premier tour face à
moi si vous voulez
ça ils ont commencé leur feuilleton
quand on a parlé de ma candidature et là
il recommence avec les mêmes et avec les
mêmes les mêmes témoignages d'ailleurs à
ça tourne en rond lors des désormais un
visage découvert mais désormais à visage
découvert on vous sait tous les actes et
ses pairs' à toutes ces femmes qui
parlent aujourd'hui qui raconte ses
abeilles et elle monte mais vous savez
c'est pas parce qu'on est une femme
qu'on ne peut pas mentir évidemment mais
c'est ce que voulait dire justement que
c'est que ces termes je n'ai jamais
agressé est ce que ram
est ce que vous pouvez jamais chose est
ce que vous pouvez imaginer que des
femmes se sentent agressés alors même
que vous ne pensez pas les avoir
agressées vous savez je ne suis pas moi
encore une fois dans vos tests
sociologique sur le ressenti ce besoin a
jugé que les faits parlent si on rentre
dans le ressenti alors là tout devient
possible un homme peut être une femme
une femme peut être un homme mon sens
adressée il ya des micros agression je
ne crois pas à tous ces thèses moderne
moi il ya les faits je n'ai jamais
agressé aucune femme
on avance a déjà une question suivante
qui arrive sur le sur la tablette
monsieur zemmour il faut juste faire
défi apparaît en asie qu'entendez vous
par chasser l'idéologie lgbt des écoles
ah bah c'est très simple il y a
aujourd'hui dans de nombreuses écoles
des associations en particulier le gvt
mais pas seulement d'ailleurs des
associations aussi antiracistes à ça
traoré et lilian thuram etc qui viennent
dans les écoles et qui endoctrinent les
enfants moi j'estime qu'ils n'ont rien à
faire dans les écoles que l'école
c'était pour apprendre à lire à écrire à
compter qu'un gros boulot pour sa vue
l'effondrement du niveau et que ces gens
là n'ont rien à faire dans les écoles
l'école doit être un sanctuaire si vous
voulez je vous donne un exemple encore
même si monsieur va dire que je prends
un exemple
mais moi je n'admets pas que on demande
à des enfants de 8 ans de 10 ans s'ils
se sentent garçon ou fille je n'admets
pas que on les pousse ensuite parfois
vers des blocages de puberté par des
médicaments je trouve ça ignoble
attendait quel rapport avec l'école
abbas est tout à fait c'est à l'école
qui ont fait cet endoctrinement vient à
l'école vous savez aujourd'hui à 25% je
crois des jeunes si j'ai vu un sondage
qui ne savent plus s'ils sont garçons
aux filles vous croyez que ça sort comme
ça ça sort comme ça vous croyez dans ma
génération on aurait fait le même
sondage on aurait trouvé quoi 0,0 à 0,1
pour cent donc vous croyez que il
différents de nous ces gamins n'ont
simplement qu'ils ont été endoctrinés
endoctrinés par des gens qui viennent
dans les écoles et qui leur racontent
que l'importance et leur ressenti et qu'
ils se sentent garçon il 68 ans vérité
c'est du baratin tout ça chez un
monsieur c'est tout simplement que
l'adolescence et l'enfance sont le lieu
on a tous été jeunes le lieu de deux dvd
de la remise en question on est troublé
par l'arrivée comme ça de la sexualité
c'est normal c'est humain à thiès vidéo
l'humanité exiger des heures dédiées
dans les collèges et les lycées à
l'éducation à la vie sexuelle et
affective ce n'est pas la peine on doit
d'abord apprendre doit donc laisser déjà
sur s'éduquer sexuellement en regardant
des vidéos sur youporn non on peut je
propose aussi un contrôle parental
systématique et déclencher
automatiquement
deuxièmement oui bah non mais c'est aux
parents de faire une télé pas
d'éducation on laisse les jeunes sans
j'ai pas eu d'éducation vous n'avez pas
eu d'éducation qu'est ce lélio au xviiie
siècle n'ont pas eu d'éducation et il
n'y avait pas de problème annoncé qu'il
n'y a pas de problèmes dans les
relations entre les hommes et les femmes
hier toujours des problèmes il y en aura
toujours bain et on a des retours des
solutions mais on n'a pas à éduquer les
gens on n'a pas à éduquer les gens les
l'éducation ce sont les parents
l'instruction c'est l'école c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que je rebaptiserait le
ministère de l'éducation nationale à
mystères de l'instruction publique parce
que justement au nom de ça au nom de
l'éducation on en est à l'endoctrinement
moi je ne veux plus de la doctrine merci
en avance avoir sur la question
pourquoi êtes vous contre le mariage
pour tous écoutez pour une raison simple
c'est que le mariage c'est un homme et
une femme le mariage c'est fait pour
protéger les enfants sinon il y aurait
pas de mariage c'est ça à l'origine de
la chose deux hommes peuvent s'aimer
évidemment ça parle aux fêtards de peser
mais évidemment ça permet à des gens
d'être plus heureux de pouvoir faire
valoir leur amour dans des cérémonies
vous savez aussi vous sert des droits
aussi plus emporté vous savez si vous
voyez toujours là je vous renverrai
l'argument de votre voisin il ya
toujours des cas individuels mais il
faut voir l'intérêt de la société
l'intérêt général dérange la société
mais parfois ça dérangerait sexe et le
genre d'éléments qui peuvent être
heureux de se marier mais comme vous
êtes dans une idéologie bisounours
idéologie bisou à gênés on vous êtes un
journaliste de la nouvelle génération
vous êtes de brut donc vous êtes un gars
de gauche progressiste et vous croyez à
toutes ces chimères c'est pas des
chimères vois autour de moi des gens qui
les guettent homosexuels et 13 euros
mais il ya ce message alors à l'armee
justement mais il faut voir un peu
globalement cher monsieur positive une
question il faut arrêter soir par
l'individualisme de votre génération et
de votre sociologie il faut aussi voir
l'intérêt général il faut être un
citoyen et non pas seulement un individu
c'est que vous avez du mal parce que
vous avez été éduqué comme ça c'est le
produit de votre génération c'est
l'occasion de votre sociologie pas ici
je connais très bien et votre génération
et vote sociologie
je vous ai souvent que je connais bien
donc il faut voir l'intérêt général
l'intérêt général c'est que le mariage
c'est un homme et une femme depuis le
logo de l'est de l'humanité si ces gens
veulent vivre ensemble moi ce que je ne
vois aucun problème je suis pour la
liberté absolue n'est pas un mariage
mais mais le mariage je trouve ça
superflu surtout qu'en fait je vais vous
dire au delà des cas individuels qu'est
ce que ça a été ça a été le moyen
justement pour les les théoriciens de
lgbt deux cas c'est ce qui s'appelle le
modèle hétérosexuel
c'est sale moi j'ai lu avec façon je
sais pas si vous l'avez lu mais c'est le
grand idéologue de des lobbys lgbt et
lui explique sa très bien casser le le
modèle hétérosexuel c'est ça l'objectif
c'est un objectif idéologique voyez que
vous allez là un objectif de rendre
heureux des gens ça ils s'en moquent
complètement règlement est ce que ça
vous appartient est ce que vous
considérez que vous abolir y est la loi
si vous étiez président de la république
ça veut donc dire des mariés des gens
nous interdire les organes et marié vous
avez raison là dessus vous avez raison
j'ai d'autres priorités je n'ai pas le
temps je jeu on va pas des maris orient
on va pas tout ça il ya un mois j'ai un
objectif c'est lutter contre le grand
remplacement et je veux ma clé à cela
assurons les choses clairement nettement
demain vous êtes président de la
république le mind et marie pas les gens
mais est-ce que les gens pourront encore
se marier mais je nageais n'abolit pas
la loi donc ça ne se voit pas mais je
dis ce que j'en pense
la plus grande crise qui arrive et celle
écologique vous président que
feriez-vous en matière d'écologie
d'abord moi je pense que la plus grande
crise qui vient et la crise migratoire
et la crise démographique en france qui
voient le peuple français être remplacé
par un autre peuple et par une autre
civilisation pour moi c'est la crise la
plus grave qui nous menace nous français
ou l'écologie peut en novembre et c'est
l'écologie l'écologie si vous voulez je
pense d'abord
qu'il y avait effectivement une crise
qui garent réchauffement climatique mais
en concédant sur les réfugiés bien sûr
mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut se
préparer justement et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut être très ferme et qu'il faut
dire à ces gens qu'on ne les recevra pas
d'avancé parce que sinon effectivement
il va encore avoir des millions de gens
qui vont venir chez nous donc en matière
d'écologie c'est simple moi je crois que
nous avons l'économie l'école l'énergie
pardon la plus décarbonés qui est le
nucléaire première chose deuxièmement je
suis pour le développement des circuits
courts au maximum les circuits localisme
merci l'écologie c'est un sujet qui
inquiète beaucoup de jeunes justement on
sait que demain par exemple pour une
manifestation justement des jeunes pour
le climat une grève pour le climat est
ce que vous les soutenez
jeu je ne soutiens pas les mouvements
qui
manifestent je ne soutiens pas ces gens
ces écologistes je ne soutiens pas
sévère allait verser la même engeance
seller toutes ces associations des
général jean ampe est extrêmement faible
portée d'un point de quelques exceptions
du général foy seven schosteck ça
plaisait couvert peut se jouer de la
politique oui mais moi c'est ces gens là
font de la politique il en a forcément
pas forcément et il avait beaucoup de
témoignages notamment sur brut et
ailleurs deux jeunes qui sont là et qui
veulent juger oui que les pousse à
dépenser 100 m ils ont peur pour leur
avenir ils ont peur ou jeu c'est loin
c'est de leur la peur pour leur avenir
c'est tout à fait légitime moi je leur
explique à ces jeunes que leur avenir si
je ne suis pas élu sera islamique et que
ça sera très grave et qu'il ne pourront
peut être libre ils ne pourront plus
simple les femmes ne pourront plus
s'habiller comme elles veulent les
garçons devront se soumettre que vous
revenez toujours ce parce que c'est le
plus important point mais il ya aussi
d'autres choses l'écologie vous pouvez
pas aller aujourd'hui il ya le rapport
du gier oui il est jeune c'est jeune si
vous voulez j'ai vu les programmes
scolaires j'ai lu les programmes
scolaires et on leur parle d'écologie
tous les quatre matins dans les
programmes il n'y a que ça est ce que
c'est exactement l'écologie lors cessé
de tout c'est plutôt une bonne chose ça
la base n'avait pas d'enfants mais c'est
pas vrai ce que vous dites c'est pas
vrai ajout jeune homme est ce que moi je
vous dis moi j'ai eu trois enfants et
moi j'ai envie d'être long dans
l'histoire juive ce n'est pas vrai
écoutez vous avec toi vous avez étudié
vous avez enseigné
n'y a pas mille ans et j'ai eu des
enfants au collège et au lycée qui sont
encore et bien vous dire que ce n'est
pas ce ne sont pas alors vous n'avez pas
vu les mêmes livres que moi fait c'est
bizarre
mobilité que moi moi j'ai j'ai connu des
programmes où on apprenait la géographie
physique voyez vous cette valve merci
mais özil et on en fait encore un petit
peu et qui ont des comptes en svt
delajoux va oui parce que c'est aussi
bon enfin bref donc tout ça pour vous
dire que je sais que ces jeunes
craignent les les réchauffements
climatiques etc je les comprends très
bien ce que vous partagez leur chance je
je partage jusqu'à un certain degré
leurs craintes at il autant ce jeu
tendance que je pense que nous nous à
nous devons faire ce qui est de notre
devoir c'est à dire je vous le répète le
nucléaire est là l'énergie la moins
carboné les circuits courts dd j'ai
prévu des plans contre pour une filière
de recyclage des plastiques pour
lutter contre le lait les terres qui
sont pollués voyez il ya des choses à
faire je suis tout à fait d'accord vous
n'êtes pas qui mais les petits qui n'ont
pas canal en avance avec eux rêvent la
question la précarité étudiante
notamment on a vu notamment pendant la
période du coville ces files d'attentes
extrêmement importante de jeunes qui
n'avaient pas de quoi se nourrir se
vêtir même parfois aussi de payer leur
loyer qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
pour lutter contre cette précarité
vous avez raison les jeunes ont beaucoup
souffert de cette période
en particulier parce qu'ils étaient
visés par des règles qui ne les
concernait pas en vérité je veux parler
de déconfinement dans le vidéo duke au
vide des règles qui ne les concernait
pas car c'était pour protéger les plus
anciens on aurait pu se débrouiller
autrement qu de façon plus plus plus
- restrictions - de restriction pour eux
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait il fallait
pas bon pour les jeunes précaires mais
bon et donc ils ont beaucoup souffert
ils ont été enfermés alors que eux ils
ne risquaient rien envoyé donc bon
c'était je n'ai pas très bien compris
cette c'est sûr réactions partout dans
le monde d'ailleurs
présidents l'ont jamais l'élément jeunes
près de l'avenue les jeunes prêtés à
travers la zone qu'est-ce qu'on fait
d'abord je pense que les jeunes sont les
premières victimes un de l'effondrement
de l'école je pense que ça compte qui
souffrent parce que l'école n'est plus
au niveau qu'elle était et je pense que
les jeunes ans outre et c'est pour ça
que j'ai toute une réforme scolaire pour
restaurer une école dean saône digne de
ce nom et cc c'est très important
deuxièmement le rapport avec un gamin
qui fait la queue attendent à ce que je
fais je fais au nom vous avez raison
mais je devais pas être là dans une
mesure deuxièmement il souffre de la
sécurité je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
jeunes souffrent d'une insécurité
terrible ils sont agressés en permanence
et c'est important donc je ferai un plan
mais c'est important parce que ça
concerne déjà dit après vous avez raison
le prix n'est pas à la question d'après
nokia fait tout précarité il ya d'abord
les précarité des étudiants et la non de
parlons bien parlons de ses jambes très
bien alors les étudiants si vous voulez
je pense effectivement qu'il faut les
aider il faut trouver des solutions pour
qu'ils se nourrissent correctement on
pourrait imaginer par exemple d d d d d
aide ponctuelle si on a vraiment des
problèmes de nourriture dont parce que
vous m'avez dit c'est à dire des jeunes
qui font la queue et tout donc comme ça
je vous avez tout à fait raison mais
c'est des aides ponctuelles maintenant
je pense que le problème majeur c'est un
problème d'adéquation entre
éducatif et professionnel
nous avons pardonné mais on parle
d'étudiants la wii mais je sais pas
après justement c'est pas après non non
non non justement justement justement je
pense que beaucoup de jeunes sont mal
dirigé au delà de l'urgence mais il ya
l'urgence vous avez raison il faut la
traiter
mais on la traite de façon ponctuelle
avec des aides etc mais au delà de les
gens je pense que les jeunes étudiants
beaucoup sont mal dirigé qu'il faudrait
développer l'apprentissage avant voyez
qu'il faudrait comme comme nous allons
le faire en supprimant le collège unique
pour pour qu'ils trouvent à un métier
plus vite plutôt dans l'ordre dans leur
développement je pense qu on y voit là
et qu'il devienne apprentis qu'ils
puissent avoir un métier
je favoriserai l'apprentissage réduirait
voyez les les charges sociales je résume
on a avancé en gros la précarité des
étudiants le problème c'est qu'ils sont
encore étudiants non je dis pas ça c'est
un peu ce que vous avez dans non jeudi
qu' il faut bien faire attention à ce
que ces jeunes ne n'aille pas dans des
filières encombré qui ne donne rien
d'accord voilà un mot peu avant mais ils
ont le droit d'être étudiant évidemment
est de faire leur choix comme ils ont
évidemment alors comment comptez-vous
obliger les pays qui refusent de
reprendre les immigrés que vous voulez
leur renvoyer à les reprendre oui
écoutez effectivement nous avons
beaucoup de pays qui refusent de signer
les fameux laissez passer consulaires
qui reprendraient leur clandestins ce
qui explique qu'on leur envoie quasiment
personne moi je pense qu'il faut faire
deux choses la première il faut
supprimer les ce qu'on appelle les
pompes aspirantes c'est à dire que les
gens de ces pays ne viendront plus si on
supprime la eme l'aide médicale d'état
si on supprime le droit du sol
c'est-à-dire que quand leurs enfants
naîtront en france ils ne seront plus
français si on supprime les allocations
sociales aux étrangers comme je le
ferais si on supprime le droit
automatique au regroupement familial
comme je le ferais donc ça c'est une
première chose de tarir les flux
deuxièmement pour les reprendre pour
répondre à la question il faut
absolument faire pression sur ces états
il ya différentes manières d'abord
supprimer l'aide au développement puis
bloqué les visas de tourisme de tous les
genres de ces pays y compris les
dirigeants puis si on monte encore s'ils
ne veulent toujours pas reprendre leurs
plans destin est d'ailleurs les
délinquants que je leur enverrai
de leur pays de leur nationalité on peut
saisir les biens qu'ils ont en france
beaucoup de ces dirigeants ont des biens
en france il n'y a aucune raison qu'on
leur fasse de cadeaux et enfin si ça ne
suffit pas je bloquerai les fonds
envoyés par les immigrés d'ici à leur
famille là-bas par la western une mesure
qui finalement ont fait en sorte que des
familles sur place souffre et qu'elles
n'ont rien à voir avec les personnes que
vous avez raison mais les français
souffrent aussi les joies je suis là
parce que vous avez géré ont fait
souffrir d'autres personnes parce que
certaines souffrent entre guillemets
signé leur gouvernement à carey price et
clandestin et plus personne ne souffrira
il n'y a pas que les clandestins votre
projet de ré migration il ya l'idée de
renvoyer des étrangers dit délinquants
dans leur pays d'origine pourquoi dit
délinquante et là alors c'est la
question que voulez vous posera pas à
quel endroit commence la délinquance
selon vous quand on est condamné mais
condamné à quoi est par exemple volé un
vélo c'est retour dans le pays d'origine
à cette très bonne question
tout délit pour un étranger il sera
renvoyé dans son pays d'origine pour
quelqu'un qui a la double nationalité à
un crime il sera renvoyé il sera déchu
de sa nationalité française et il sera
renvoyé et à trois délits il sera déchu
de sa nationalité il sera renvoyé vous
êtes arrivé à ce à quoi il va servir
de grille de documentation et de vie en
gris connaissent savent bien jouer enfin
c'est la nourrice avait deux logiquement
chez vous mais c'est très simple je
pense qu'un étranger doit bien se
comporter chez nous on l'a reçu on la
nourrit on l'a aidé on a mis ses enfants
à l'école on lui a donné même des aides
sociales etc eux aussi vous receviez
quelqu'un chez vous et que vous fassiez
tout ça et qu'après ils saccagent votre
appartement et qu' ils vous agresse où
ils agressent votre fils ou votre fille
qu'est ce que vous feriez vous le
mettrez dehors et bah c'est ce que je
fais
le thème de l'immigration il ya pendant
longtemps vous l'avez refusé pourquoi
tout d'un coup vous nous allons vous
l'avez mais en plus vous en faites un
ministère c'est pas que je les refuse et
c'est que
je ne voulais pas rentrer dans cette
polémique larry nance est dans cette
discussion la monétique mais parce qu'il
n'ya pas il n'ya pas il n'y a pas à
refuser certains mots il n'y a pas vous
savez quand quand j'ai parlé de grand
remplacement on m'a dit exactement la
même chose c'est un mot utilisé par
l'extrême droite parce qu'il faudrait
faire et c était vrai oui mais vous avez
vu dans mystery n'a qu'a bien mais vous
avez vu les emmène à bord c'est vrai un
an 67 % de la dépense et je vais vous
dire il il y aura on aura la même chose
c'est à dire que l'on va s'apercevoir
avec les premiers sondages qui vont
sortir que plus de 60% des français
pensent que c'est très bien l'armee
création qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire le renvoi des étrangers qui ne
sont plus désirable en france c'est tout
en en jeunes allez-y chantier de
nouvelles questions
lui même date les mêmes tvrm rice savoir
qu'est ce que votre vote et s'est rangé
au niveau local merci je suis contre le
droit de vote des étrangers aux
élections locales le droit de vote est
lié à la citoyenneté française il n'y a
aucune raison qu'un étranger vote et moi
je vais plus loin je pense que comme je
les dis
un étranger n'a pas non plus droit aux
aides sociales de la solidarité
nationale et donc avec moi ils ne les
aura plus et jeu même s'ils cotisent à
c'est pas la même chose vous savez il ya
vous savez très bien il ya le
la sécurité sociale c'est à dire qui
correspond à une assurance vous avez
raison on cotise et donc on a le droit à
la centale alors le bourg seulement de
la santé la retraite etc ça je ne touche
pas je parle des allocations sociales on
appelle dans le jargon technocratique
non contributives c'est à dire pour
lesquels il n'y a pas de cotisations
sociales le rsa l'allocation logement
les allocations familiales qui sont
financés par le budget de l'état voilà
par exemple pour des français donc voit
sa wii vous savez je suis assez vieux
contrairement
à vous qui moi j'ai connu dans les
années 70-80 à peu prés jusqu'aux années
90 il y avait des prestations sociales
réservées aux français c'est même dans
le code de la sécurité sociale la
solidarité nationale voyez ce qui
réservé aux nationaux et puis à partir
des années 90 il ya eu un basculement on
a volontairement
plus fait de distinction entre
citoyens nationaux et étrangers c'est
dans le cadre de l'europe il y avait
toute une idéologie dont vous voulez la
réintroduire exact question suivante
s'il vous plaît bonjour monsieur zemmour
on aimerait bien savoir avec mon
collègue
les ivan semblait possible en france
selon
les ensembles non mais cette expression
est d'abord elle était formée elle est
dévoyée elle et je vais pas faire un
court mais elle est tirée d'un texte
célèbre d'ernest renan sur qu'est ce
qu'une nation qui disait
si
l'on s'approprie l'histoire de ce pays
si les assimile en gros on va pouvoir
vivre ensemble et c'était un verbe et
non pas un substantif et en plus c'est
le fameux plébiscite de tous les jours
mais il faut bien comprendre que on ne
peut vivre ensemble quels que soient son
origine son sa religion et c'est que si
on a et c'est le c'était le sens du
texte de renan que si l'on adopte un 1-1
des moeurs commune une histoire commune
dd d'un mode 2d mode de vie commun
aujourd'hui c'est exactement l'inversé
on appelle vivre ensemble la possibilité
de vivre côte à côte avec des moeurs et
des modes de vie et des histoires et des
héros différent pour moi je crois que ce
n'est pas possible que vous pointez du
doigt des gens qui ont parlé des prénoms
dits français ce que pensait pas
justement ce vivre ensemble vous vous
toucher vous pointez du doigt des gens
qu'ils sont d'abord je ne pointe du
doigt personne je dis simplement que il
y avait une loi qui imposait des prénoms
français c'était la loi jusqu'en 1993
mais ce que c'est pas quelque chose
qu'un changement est ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour respecter la loi fa c'est
une première chose si on ne respecte pas
avoir parlé d'autre chose mais d'abord
il y avait une loin on va parler de la
loi dans un esprit et ensuite cette loi
n'était pas respectée pour les gens qui
sont nés avant 1993 deuxièmement depuis
je pense que je vous répète pour moi
pour être d accord vous pouvez être
multiculturaliste vous avez le droit
mais ça peut vous avez nommé vous avez
le noir moi je gère mon opinion
personnelle c'est juste si cette chose
salut droit une opinion perd ce n'est
pas une question d'opinion personnelle
c'est juste de savoir de se dire que des
gens qui sont parfaitement intégrés dans
la société et qui peuvent avoir la
société française ton et prénom à
connotation ou des prénoms étrangers
vont se sentir pointer du doigt est ce
que dans une campagne où justement j'ai
sujet ça vole pas toujours très haut est
ce que dans une campagne où justement il
ya des questions que je suis important
de pouvoir d'achat faire une semaine
dessus a comme conséquence que la farcir
le débat public hasard c'est vous qui
estimé ce qui est important pas non moi
je l'appelle là même qui mangeait mal
appliquée et vous savez je lis mes
courriers reçus mais moi je n'ai pas
être oubliée par les nazis pour savoir
comment ça se voit c'est important c'est
à nos armoires de prénom c'est pas
anodin c'est le symbole de la
défrancisation
je vous le dis c'est le symbole de la
défrancisation donc je pense qu'il faut
repréciser les français et les étrangers
est ce que c'est vraiment une prise
agrégé un doigt la situation actuelle
dans notre pays la guerre aux portes de
l'europe le pouvoir d'achat pour moi le
plus important c'est le remplacement du
peuple français par un autre peuple et
me dire qu'il ya d'autres choses qui
sont aussi importantes on peut être
soucieux de la fin du mois et est aussi
soucieux de la fin de la france et non
qui permettra à changer quelque chose
c'est un fameux tube je veux aussi vous
a fait c'est un quand on appelle
plus ses enfants avec des prénoms de
l'histoire de france de la tradition
française badler française ça veut dire
que l'on ne veut pas vivre selon les
schémas et le vote de vie effréné examen
c'est tout ce que ça vaut une petite
déclare claire il ne peut y avoir dans
d'autres précisions faire une phrase que
vous avez prononcé au journal de 20
heures de tf1 en décembre 2021 au moment
où vous avez annoncé votre candidature
vous avez appelé j'appelle tous les
musulmans à s'assimiler et à renoncer à
la pratique de l'islam qui impose un
code juridique et politique est ce que
ça veut dire que pour vous un bon
musulman n'est plus un musulman
non ce n'est pas exactement cela d'abord
j'appelle effectivement tous les
musulmans à s'assimiler comme les
générations d'immigrés dans le passé
l'ont fait les espagnols les italiens
mais les polonais les brouillards
renault et ses terres à renault et à
renoncer à l'islam comme un code
juridico politique c'est pas comme ça
que voulez-vous prononce ici c'est comme
ça bien sûr mais pas sûr parce que
l'islam c'est deux choses j'ai déjà dit
expliqué sam hill fois l'islam c'est une
fois c'est une pratique mais c'est aussi
ce que j'appelle la un code juridique
politique c'est à dire une loi une loi
ce qu'on appelle la charia par exemple
exécuter les homosexuels par exemple
enfermer les femmes sous un voile par
exemple ne pas se se méfier des
chrétiens et des juifs voir les
combattre tout ça c'est dans le coran
tout ça c'est dans l'islam c'est dans
les hadiths qui sont le bleu les grandes
histoires de mahomet qui est le bel
exemple tout cela c'est de tout cela
dont les musulmans doivent se défaire
pour devenir français sinon sinon il ya
incompatibilité entre l'islam et la
république française donc donc j'appelle
les musulmans oui à avoir une pratique
de l'islam compatible avec la france les
moeurs de la france etc comme l'ont fait
les autres comme l'ont fait toutes les
générations d'immigrés ce n'est pas en
clair ce n'est pas à la france de faire
des accommodements raisonnables avec
l'islam c'est à l'islam de faire des
accommodements raisonnables avec la
france je ne dit pas autre chose et et
s'ils font cela mais parce que je pense
qu'ils peuvent le faire qu'il y en a
déjà qui ont commencé à le faire les en
particulier les kabyles l'ont fait très
bien donc je la plains bleu vert ou ce
donc ils peuvent le faire évidemment est
donc là ils seront mes frères comme tous
mes compatriotes ça c'est intéressant
parce que chez les identitaires c'est un
vrai problème différence avec vous je
considère que l'assimilation c'est une
erreur une résister impossible ils sont
encore dans le choc des civilisations
mais remise le choc des civilisations
n'est pas incompatible avec la
simulation vous vous trompez pas c'est
pas moi qui disait on peut on peut
changer de civilisation
on et moi je suis né mes ancêtres sont
nés dans une civilisation
arabo-musulmane et on est venu on est en
france on est on est venu dans la
civilisation française annoncée pardon
c'est assimilé à la civilisation
française c'est exactement ce que je
demande à aux français de confession
musulmane voilà dernière petite question
à n'a rien d'extraordinaire teissonnière
question est ce qu'un président doit
avoir un casier judiciaire vierge
si c'est à moi que vous faites référence
simple jeu j'estime que moi j'ai été
condamné pour défendre mes opinions et
qui est en plus la justice est
instrumentalisée par des associations
qui veulent me combattre politiquement
et qui n'ont pas le courage de me
combattre politiquement parce que le
peuple est d'accord avec moi et qui
utilise la justice vous fait dire
clairement que je suis condamné par la
justice mais je n'ai volé personne ce
qui vous fait jaillir avec le sac d'une
vieille dame oui vous faites là rien à
voir qu'est ce qui vous fait dire que le
peuple est d'accord avec vous les
sondages récents ajustements sont en
dessous de 10% par année on entend
d'abord je suis pas on ne se dit pas
pour certains ici non et deuxièmement et
deuxièmement moi je vous parle des
sondages sur les thèmes voilà quand on
demande aux français si l'islam est
dangereux pour la république française
ainsi il y a trop d'immigrés si le grand
remplacement nous menacent là il y en a
entre 60 et 70% des français qui sont
d'accord avec moi j'ai juste eric sont
vengés une toute toute dernière question
sur l'art émigration précisément cite
ainsi un étranger en situation légale en
france mais à l'étranger en france est
accusé pour liberté d'expression et skil
et rémy grey dont il ne sera plus
accusés pour liberté d'expression de moi
je respecterai la liberté d'expression
de quoi rappeler de loi il ya plus de 1
il y aura plus on dit ce qu'on veut on
pense qu'on va en france mais là plus de
cadre légal à ce choc qu'on ne dise plus
qu'on ne dit pas que dans ce passé nous
donner une évolution de noix non mais
vous avez aux états unis il y a le
premier amendement qui fait respecter la
liberté je trouve ça très bien donc on
vient on dit américain c'est au nom de
votre part vous voyez il faut prendre ce
qui est bien dans les américains merci
merci à vous